[Music]
we're back chuck
yes we are i don't let this alone you
know there's too much stuff out there
that people
i think that need some explaining that's
you guys explain it to the neoliberal
explaining to do
i got it thank you ricky ricardo yes no
that was actually my mother-in-law
all right so i thought it was time
to talk about flying cars okay well now
that we're on the subject since you
bought it up
okay uh you and your kind
all of you people okay uh
what the hell where is my flying car
my people yeah you people you know
you people the scientists and engineers
you science
people that's true that is true no one
will come up to the comedian and say
where's my flying car exactly nobody's
coming up to me and
complaining okay you believe it man all
these years i said we're gonna have a
flying car
and what did you do chuck you didn't do
a damn thing no
okay it's you guys who were supposed to
have us
in flying cars all right here you go i
have an unorthodox
account of this are you ready go ahead
okay so first
uh i we already have flying cars they're
called helicopters
okay um but you don't think of it as a
flying car but it kind of is it lifts up
goes through the air drops down they're
really noisy
notice and
if the engine fails and the rotors fail
on a helicopter
it becomes a brick whereas if your
engine fails
on your car you just roll over to the
side of the road so there are dangers
there is noise
there is well where you're going to land
it how are you going to park it so
they're practical issues
related to it but that's not why i
called this session with you
okay okay i want to say we already have
flying cars
in ways you haven't thought about and
here it is ready uh-oh this sounds to me
like
how my father told me why we didn't go
to disneyland because we already been to
disneyland
because great adventure it's just as
good as disneyland
okay we didn't even go to great
adventure and he's like well
guess what hershey park is great
adventure and great adventure
it's disneyland as far as actually park
has rides
they all got rides you've been you've
been to one you've been to a mall
all right then i should stop now that
one sounds like your father
all right here it goes go ahead go ahead
let's unpack
why you want flying cars in the first
place okay all right
yes so i'm gonna tell you all right
imagine a road
that's only two lanes one in one
direction one or the other so here you
are
you're driving and a car stalls in front
of you right
that backs up every single car behind
you absolutely that's not
wise no it is that's not good that's
right it's because you're traveling in
only one dimension
okay you're traveling along a line the
line has one dimension it only has
length
and you say to yourself let me be clever
let's travel
in two dimensions okay is that just on
the shoulder of the road to get around
exactly so instead of one lane road for
you
let's give it two lanes that way if a
car stalls
the traffic can still move that's it oh
my gosh what an advance on
transportation
that is well i got to tell you the
nascent stages of transportation
development those people were really
stupid
no no they were very excited let's not
just have a one-lane road let's have a
two-lane road
and then as this got good to people they
say well let's make the two dimensions
even bigger
so now you have three lanes four lanes
the 405 in la is six
lanes plus shoulders on each side
okay so if any one car is slow or pokey
or stalled
all the traffic can move around it fine
so
now we have so many people with cars
we have clogged our two-dimensional
system of travel
right it's clogged so you say to
yourself you're stuck in traffic i wish
my car could elevate and then
move through the air so what you want
now is a third dimension
yes okay so not for one dimension of one
lane
not the two dimensions of of multiple
lanes
you want the third dimension of space
i love air the air above that's really
what you're after correct
that's correct okay because when you do
that you're no longer in the traffic
okay and you can just bypass the traffic
entirely
okay so okay the quick sign
what i got to just say this what you
just said is exactly the case because
i happen to be with somebody who owns a
plane and we went down the pacific coast
highway on a friday night
and there was nothing but red tail
lights for miles and miles and miles
and he was like this is why you have a
plane
okay look at those suckers okay so hold
on but just to be clear
you don't want a flying car to go from
new york to l.a
we have airplanes for that okay the
flying car
i think is entirely motivated by
avoiding traffic
yes okay i think i understand this
correctly
yes you don't say i wish i had a flying
car to no
to to go to europe no we have fast
airplanes
fine so let's get back to being stuck in
traffic in the 12 lane 405
in downtown l.a so now you want to say
let me go up to a third dimension
yes that will solve everything you say
to yourself okay
so what you're after is not a flying car
you're after a third dimension okay new
york city
has already done that new york city
has flying cars it's called the subway
oh come on man it's called
that's what it is i just want my blind
car to smell like
urine so there you are
stuck in traffic and you say let me go
into a third dimension
it is not above it's below so you go
down to the third dimension
and you bypass all of that traffic
the smell of hobo p frustration
and anger oh you you talk like hobo p
smell different from your pee
no well you got me there
[Laughter]
so my point is anything that takes you
into another dimension is the
dimensional equivalent of a flying car
and we know this
that's why the interstate
does not have stop lights any road that
crosses it
goes into the third dimension to get
where it's going
so you have underpasses you have
crossovers bridges
right so that your traffic is not
stopped
i'm telling you society fundamentally
has invoked the principles of flying
cars
without the noise and the danger of it
wow okay that sounds very much
like i know that this burger is made out
of tofu
but because we call it a burger
it's a burger no
[Laughter]
no so so
what the future needs is more bridges
and tunnels
all right so what do you think about the
hyperloop then
the hyperloop so that's that's for
traveling longer distances like between
cities that it would replace trains and
short
uh flight so i i have my skepticisms of
the
of the technology and to make it
practical but
if if elon is dreaming it up i'm not
going to stand in the way of
anyone who dreams about a future
because even if it doesn't work there's
other stuff that they're innovating to
make it happen that could end up
spinning off and completely transforming
our lives for the better
as this does anytime anyone has done it
before
so i'm not in his way keep going for the
hyperloop it's so it's a tube it's a
tube that
uses interesting physics so that you can
have very high acceleration at high
speeds
right much higher than a a a
a train and it rivals the speeds that
planes reach
when they're going to nearby cities like
new york to boston new york to dc
or la to san francisco those distances
are not so
large that the plane would get really
high and go very fast right
so it doesn't it so it keeps a lower
speed to do that and that's fine it
works for you
so i'm just telling you chuck we've
already delivered you
the flying cars and it's called the new
york city subway system
man no and you don't sound very
satisfied by it i just i'm not set
i want to i want to fly my own car
and i want to be george jetson the black
george jetson the black one
effects how does that go
thank you do that again let me hear it
so so yeah and
all right but a flying car
they had flying cars they were like
flying saucers really flying cars
saucers
with a little radio transmitter out the
back here's the point have you ever
heard a drone
that you can hold in your hand uh hover
in front of you
yes you basically can't conduct a
conversation with anyone else in the
room
because of the noise the propeller
blades are making and that's the noise
it's making
to provide enough thrust to hold up a
simple
gopro camera okay now
let's hold your ass up in the third
dimension
how much noise are those rotors making
we still have the noise abatement
problem that is not solved
i'm going to say when it comes to flying
cars
hearing is overrated
where do you what's what school of
comedy will you trade the macabre school
of comedy
well now that's a very good point i
never thought of it that way because the
i i have seen these very small drones
and you're right it is hard to hold a
conversation if a drone is hovering
and two of them you can't hear yourself
so correct
that okay almost every almost every
youtube commercial or any other
commercial
where they show drones moving around and
they're talking to you you can't hear
the drone
you can't hear the drone yeah okay so
now let let me ask you this because
they'll remove the soundtrack of the
driver
you can't have that conversation there's
never been a drone shot where you hear
the drone
that's how loud they are you're
absolutely right uh yeah you okay
all right let me ask you this real quick
because i know we're uh we're out of
time okay we're out of time
is there any way that in sci-fi movies
that the earth's magnetic field can be
manipulated to create
flight because that is the premise
behind all
hovering vehicles in the future is that
somehow
they are able to take the magnetic field
of the earth
and just rest upon it
in such a way or focus it in such a way
that it can create flight okay so you
remember
compasses remember those yeah the needle
points north okay
remember that okay if you remove the
cover of the compass
okay so the entire strength of earth's
magnetic field
is operating on that little needle and
it's got it pointing north
take your finger and just spin it
it'll spin okay yeah it'll go crazy
it'll spin like a roulette wheel
you could spin it like a roulette wheel
which means the strength of earth's
magnetic field
ain't [ __ ] okay
your finger can override what it's
trying to do to a needle
it ain't [ __ ] well they use the excuse
no
no no that that listen that's right
there so the the strength of magnetic
field on maglev's
maglev's is way stronger than that of
anything
earth's magnetic field is creating the
magnetically levitated trains
right so then you would have to create
that infrastructure in order to have
that so there we go
correct and i'll tell you something
quick i was visiting china
and the world's largest telescope there
when we were filming for for
um cosmos and the nearest large airport
there is shanghai
so i'm there and there's all these you
know it's like any other airport it's
big and airy and
there's all these signs with symbols for
things
so you know what the bathroom looks like
that symbol and food
it's got a knife and fork or chopsticks
whatever and so there it is
and then in there there was a symbol i
didn't quite understand
and it was right next to like the
bathroom symbol and the food symbol
and i said oh my gosh that's the signal
for the magnetically levitated train
so a sign that china is actually living
in the future in ways that we have yet
to connect not to not to worry american
exceptionalism
one day we'll have maglev toilets
that's that's the sign you'll see at jfk
take that china as i float above
my throne oh that's so that way your
butt cheeks don't even touch the toilet
seat
i have no problem using public bathrooms
because i use a maglev
toilet that is brilliant chuck except
you have to embed your butt cheeks
with a magnetic uh you know you have to
be magnetized somehow so you need
surgical implants
yeah we're still working out the details
[Laughter]
i can just picture this go to the maglev
bathroom and everyone is just floating
there above the toilet
there you go right and we all have
spectacular asses because of it
that means it's time to end this
explainer okay
all right everything you never wanted to
know about
mad what what the hell were we talking
about yes
we're flying cars flights how do we end
up with
maglev toilets from flying cars i'm
gonna tell you this
i accept your uh explanation on the
transportation
aspects that we have conquered that part
you know in the dimensions all right
in the realm of dimensions we have
conquered that yes
i totally do not accept the idea that
that's equivalent to a flying car
i'm sorry i've been cheated your people
have cheated me
okay do you remember the hoverboard okay
from back to the future
part two i still want one okay however
and then someone came out with a product
they called the hoverboard
except it had wheels wheels yeah all
right and i'm thinking
who are you fooling here this is not why
you calling it hoverboard then i thought
about it
i thought about it go ahead the
hoverboard and back to the future
um it doesn't work if you ride it off a
cliff
it doesn't work over water it maintains
a few inch distance above the floor the
ground okay
just like a skateboard
so the hoverboard was not really
much of an advance on anything it's like
saying let's make exactly what a
skateboard is
except it's not touching the ground but
you can't do anything different with it
than you did with a skateboard
so where's the invention why did you
waste my time
i'm just saying hey all right well you
know what it's like a flying car that
can only hover
a foot off the ground it's not a flying
car give me wheels
no you got me you got you got that one
right you're absolutely okay so i was
initially harsh
on the battery operated hoverboard and
then i said it's doing exactly
what the one does it back to the future
and who cares if their wheel's touching
the ground it's the same thing
true true and and it makes for
really good instagram videos where
people fall and break their arms
so again the macabre school of comedy
that's
from rich chuck i'm sorry yeah
what's wrong with me today all right we
got way over time here
okay all right all right we good that
was flying cars check so don't ever
bug me about that again all right
flying cars equals the new york city
subway this way
you're in soaked subways all right this
has been a star talk explainer
neil degrasse tyson here